yesterday
this channel was deemed too dangerous
and harmful by youtube
as many of you know we had the live
stream going we had plan b on plan b was
dropping bombs he was dropping bombs
about the economy about monetary policy
about bitcoin about the stock to flow
ratio where he thought bitcoin's price
could go at one point he said that over
the next couple of years he could see
bitcoin anywhere between a million to
five million dollars real harmful
educational stuff going on here
and so right towards the end of the
stream all of a sudden we thought we
shut off the stream and then there was
people who were watching and they got
told that the stream ended abruptly and
the channel was deleted
and when i went to refresh the page it
said the channel was deleted so that's
weird maybe it's just a glitch then i
checked my email and we had a couple of
emails from youtube here's the first one
our team has or i'm sorry this is the
second email that i received our team
has reviewed your content and
unfortunately we think it violates our
harmful and dangerous policy that's
right ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls you are watching the most
dangerous business show in the world
right here live on youtube
we've removed the following content from
youtube thanks so much susan and team
and we know that this might be
disappointing but it's important to us
that youtube is a safe place for all
again best business show very dangerous
place gotta make sure it's safe if the
content breaks our rules we remove it
great rule if you think we've made a
mistake you can appeal it we'll take
another look keep reading for more
details
again we then had another piece of
information shared by youtube
we then were told what the policy says
content that encourages illegal
activities that's right our show is so
dangerous that we encourage illegal
activities or incites users to violate
youtube's guidelines is not allowed on
youtube the taliban is allowed on
youtube the ccp is allowed on youtube
but the most dangerous business show is
not permitted
we may allow depictions of such
activities if they are educational or
documentary in nature and don't help
others imitate them again the
educational business and finance show
does not qualify under the educational
claws in their policies
when uploading a video make sure you
post as much information as possible in
the title which is actually not what
you're supposed to do on youtube and
description to help us and your viewers
understand the primary purpose of the
video
so then
it says we get another email this is the
last email i got from youtube i think
they got tired of emailing they said how
this affects your channel
we have permanently removed your channel
from youtube we were de-platformed and
it says going forward you won't be able
to access possess or create any other
youtube channels
susan wojcikeski who is the ceo of
youtube i apologize that i'm saying or
not her name incorrectly and the others
at youtube d
us and tried to cancel us on their
platform well
that's great but guess what
we're here
and they didn't cancel us they didn't
de-platform us so what exactly happened
if we then look at
what transpired
i just took the emails and i started
tweeting them and i started to say wait
a second this is pretty absurd
and
that caught the attention of a lot of
people because guess what censorship and
d-platforming is a really sensitive
issue right now because
it's okay
when they do it to somebody else that
you disagree with but when they come for
you all of a sudden everyone gets really
worried and nervous
and so it's not only important to talk
about these issues when it's affecting
you it's also actually really important
to talk about issues of censorship and
de-platforming when it's happening to
people that you may disagree with or
that you may think don't really matter
to what you're interested in and so when
i started to tweet we had everyone from
people in silicon valley to senators to
congressmen all tweeting support or
commentary the first david sacks said
the use of a censorship power that we
were promised would only be used in the
most extreme cases has become absolutely
routine and largely
inexplicable so again
this was originally promised this idea
that they could take you off a platform
only for the most dangerous people in
society people that absolutely were
spreading misinformation and were
putting people in danger that sounded
pretty good at first
now all of a sudden they've come for the
most dangerous business show
without really any sort of explanation
and also youtube eventually told us that
one single employee some employee that
nobody knows the name of that nobody
knows how to hold accountable got to
make the decision by themselves there
was one employee who was the manual
reviewer they watched the content they
said we think this is not good on our
platform and they would with a click of
a button we're able to completely delete
the channel and de-platform us
i don't think that we want to live in a
society where some random manual human
reviewer has the ability to hit the kill
switch
and just cancel somebody off the
platform
but to that human reviewer sorry you
probably had a bad day yesterday
we're still here nobody knows who you
are
and the problem is with these systems
no one person should have all that power
shout out kanye west
because it's ridiculous that there is no
review process there's no checks and
balances there's nothing the default
action is
they just can cancel you they can just
de-platform you even when they make a
mistake but remember the reason why we
came back
is because not only folks like david
sachs were able to amplify it but then
here we have elected officials we have
senator lummus saying yet another canary
in the coal mine what are way what are
ways for access to uh what are ways for
access to information to flourish how
can lawmakers support censorship
resistance no mandates but protection of
freedoms like the freedom of speech
again
i've got a million followers on twitter
so i'm able to get the word out but
there are hundreds if not thousands of
people who every single year get
cancelled or de-platformed or censored
on platforms like youtube
it's absurd they don't have the
privilege and the benefit of other large
audiences to go to and yell and scream
and make a bunch of noise to get the
attention of youtube and the executives
and the team there
instead what ends up happening is they
get thrown into and lost in a entire
series of automated
customer service flows no phone number
to call and frankly they're just
forgotten they're completely wiped from
the internet many of those hundreds or
thousands of people have spent hours and
hours
lots of time and energy
and mental cycles working their asses
off to build their audience to build
content for the platform trying to
follow the rules and with one click of a
button
one random employee
that is nameless and faceless
can just kick you right off the platform
it's not the society we want to live in
congressman davidson also chiming in
saying a distributed ledger platform for
free speech
needs user-friendly mass adoption
swiftly there are clearly alternatives
to youtube twitter facebook even google
but authoritarian impulses at big tech
are spreading like contagion
again this isn't some conspiracy theory
of top-down thought process as to the
big tech executives got into a room and
they collude with each other to silence
one individual person
youtube clearly stated on twitter
a random employee with a kill switch
can just cancel us right off the
platform
does that random employee have training
who holds them accountable or will they
be punished for their inaccurate action
what ends up being
the repercussions
we didn't make a mistake
and yesterday we were punished
and all we got was an apology
so what happens how do they prevent this
from happening in the future
well
the short answer is we don't know
but the fact that there's one random
nameless faceless employee at google who
has the power to do this and if they can
do it to us with 250 000 subscribers
they can do it to anyone
it's not just about us
it's just the fact that maybe they
shouldn't have the ability without
checks and balances without the ability
to filter
what is the reason why the employee's
punching the button doesn't make a lot
of sense to us
on top of that the only reason why
you're watching this right this second
is because we literally made so much
noise and had so many people chiming in
that eventually we were trending on
twitter
the average person on youtube can't do
that
they can't rally an entire community
yell and scream to have people both
publicly supporting it and raising hell
but also privately a bunch of people
who've asked not to be named calling up
folks that they know at youtube whether
it's some sort of partnership person or
people who are higher up and saying hey
what is going on
again this isn't something where we
violated the policies this isn't
something where we were doing something
nefarious or spam or trying to
steal money from people or anything like
that
it was simply that they deemed the
content harmful and dangerous
and so if a show on personal finance
and business education can be deemed
dangerous and harmful and with the click
of a button of a nameless faceless
employee at google can be thrown off the
platform and you can be told that not
only is your current channel being
removed but you also will not be allowed
to create new channels and to start over
maybe we should start asking ourselves
what
is the process what are the rules
because this is no longer the best
business show in the world it's now the
most dangerous business show in the
world and if we have the most dangerous
business show in the world
maybe
everyone's dangerous
and who gets to decide who's dangerous
and harmful
well it's not us it's not the public
some random employee at faith or at a
google that random employee at google
right now is telling all of us
we don't want this content anymore
so you know what we're gonna do today
we're gonna give away one dollar for
every single like we get on this video
youtube doesn't like what we're doing
we're just gonna double and triple down
if you think we're dangerous and harmful
wait till you see what we have planned
because if they deem sharing information
about what people should do from an
investing standpoint getting involved in
business owning equity making sure
they're protected from unreal levels of
unemployment and inflation and they're
being told a story by the incumbents and
the experts that ends up not being
accurate we're just gonna sit here and
keep telling the truth and if they
eventually take us off the platform
okay
says more about them than it does about
us because all we're talking about is
personal finance but again it's
dangerous it's harmful and as my
brothers and i grew up
you know sometimes you just gotta be the
dangerous guys i was gonna say you kept
saying how the show's dangerous you woke
up feeling dangerous today
i mean listen
the fact that we got cancelled
off the platform is absurd
yeah but what's more absurd is that we
got back in four hours and there's
people who have been taken off the
platform 30 days ago 60 days ago 90 days
ago and they got no ability to do what
we did yeah that aren't doing anything
wrong right people that have done no uh
haven't broken any of the rules haven't
received any strikes exactly what
happened to us but haven't don't have
the audience or the ability to go out
there and promote it and say hey we need
to get back on of course it's absurd the
reason why i'm bringing up the fact that
there's people with large audiences from
silicon valley et cetera that they're
senators and congressmen right we know
that that is absurd that they were all
uh spreading this message and amplifying
it's because censorship and d
platforming is so sensitive right now
but on top of that
the fact that we're able to make that
much noise
protects us so actually part of the
protection from censorship or
de-platforming is the fact that we have
other large audiences that we can then
mobilize to actually make enough noise
but if you're just some random person on
youtube who's got an account and you've
got five or ten thousand uh subscribers
and you're creating content and one day
you just show up to your account and
it's literally just taken off the
platform
there's nothing you can do i didn't
speak to one person at youtube yesterday
right i
went through the email i couldn't even
figure out how to actually chat with
somebody at all these links like oh go
here and you can chat go here and you
can chat all the chat functions are in
your account but if your account's
deleted you can't chat with anybody
so anybody who's doing product
management at google you might want to
fix that but on top of that
not only is it absurd that they actually
de-platform people like this
we're talking about a situation
no strikes no warnings no anything
this is just pure
individual one person that youtube
according to what youtube said publicly
one person made a mistake
they can cancel you they can d platform
and then they can prevent you from ever
using the platform again
makes no sense to me
yeah i think that i mean this is why if
you looked on twitter yesterday i
appreciate all y'all by the way y'all
saved the show let's be honest facts
yeah facts they went on twitter everyone
was causing an uproar and that helped so
appreciate it i was dying laughing we
had a team meeting afterwards i was
prescheduled and we sat there for about
half the meeting and i was just reading
through tweets of people saying they
were cancelling their youtube tv they
were tweeting at susan after i told her
to call me she didn't call but then they
were also saying all kinds of crazy
stuff uh and that's exactly what ended
up bringing it back is literally
youtube has to respond when you make
that much noise without you all we don't
bring the show back we don't bring the
channel back but we have a very explicit
advantage that other people don't have
and that's the part that frankly pissed
me off is because when we were going
through it i was annoyed yeah it was
super dumb but like i get the game i've
been living on the internet for years
now i know if we make enough noise we'll
eventually get in front of them we
didn't do anything wrong they'll say
it's a mistake they'll apologize and
they'll give us the channel back
but if i didn't have the big audience if
we didn't have all of you
you've been screwed it was very obvious
that there's no way to actually appeal
this there's no way to get the channel
back
unless you have a big big audience
somewhere else
but i was gonna say like this is the
what i got from it yesterday was like
this is the exact reason why people want
to implement decentralized protocols
against uh for legacy systems that we
use today and networks that we use today
like youtube and other platforms right
and the idea was right david sacks is
completely right like
centralized protocols and systems and
networks provide a lot of value right
there's a reason why facebook was able
to scale so quickly youtube et cetera
and all these platforms really work well
but david was right in the in the aspect
that when you give them an inch they
take a mile right and we were promised
that the ability to censor someone or
take them off the platform or ban them
or limit who can see their content with
the algorithm and all this stuff was
only going to be used for the craziest
people in the world and people who were
spewing misinformation and harmful
information and dangerous information
illegal information and that's clearly
not the truth right what do we talk
about we talk about financial education
we give away money we're paying off uh
we're paying for people's groceries
we're sending people to a football game
we bought a guy jordan's the other day
dangerous [ __ ] yeah like you know
[ __ ] right but it just comes down to
then one single person at youtube
a massive massive massive company has
the ability to go in and shut off
someone's channel it's ridiculous it
shouldn't be happening and this is just
showing how far it's come right like
from the ability of this used to be a
major major major decision right the ceo
would be most likely involved when
you're talking about ten years ago uh
eight ten years ago banning someone off
the platform now it can literally happen
from one individual who's reviewing your
content deciding he didn't agree with
that day and removing you from the
platform and thank god right to the
point of million followers on twitter
those tweets got millions and millions
of impressions you're telling the ceo of
youtube to call you
so like all this stuff helps and you can
make noise trending on twitter and it
gets the ability to get the channel back
in two three hours other people are not
lucky and i think that's the important
piece from it is like the decentralized
protocols are important for people who
cannot defend themselves in a public
nature john what do you think
it's absurd we got d platformed we got
uh they came for you john that's
censored yeah what's your god is the
most dangerous
no i think it's absurd i mean there has
to be a review process in some sense for
bad content on the internet um i
personally think that is because look if
if you see something bad the
misinformation and the dangerous part
are kind of two separate things
misinformation is you can like it's
misinformation the dangerous part is you
can block someone do all that but they
have to do something internally as a
centralized company uh ridiculous that
the best business show got uh got
censored though
giving away cash free education all
right now that we got the serious stuff
out of the way listen here we the
captain now we're the captain now you
don't d-platform us we d-platform you
the only thing i'm willing to accept
from the youtube team the only thing is
put us on the homepage and give us
another 250 000 subscribers then we'll
call it even so that to me feels like a
fair trade you take us down you
embarrass us you really uh hurt us our
audience they lost the last end of the
stream there's really educational
information there you want to make it up
to us put us on the homepage give us 250
000 subscribers we'll call it even we'll
tell everyone youtube's great fair trade
fair trade